minor to the main stories from today's
budget the Chancellor is being accused
of breaking a conservative manifesto
pledge by increasing the national
insurance contributions that the
self-employed pay and small businesses
have been given some relief over
impending business rate changes with a
four hundred and thirty five million
pound package including the 300 million
pound fund for local authorities to
distribute target individual hard cases
were here to discuss the method measures
are Helen Dickinson the chief executive
of the British Retail Consortium men
many of whose members have feared for
their future over the rate shake-up and
Chris Bryce whose chief executive of the
association of independent professionals
and the self-employed so Helen let me
start with you were you happy with what
Philip Hammond announced today four
hundred and thirty five million pounds I
think the response from our membership
although retailers that I've spoken to
has been perhaps lukewarm let me say so
really welcomed the reliefs that have
been offered for small businesses for
high streets up and down the country but
in the scheme of things that's the sort
of another sort of temporary
sticking-plaster to a system that is is
fundamentally broken and not fit for
purpose of the 21st century so have you
had much feedback from members this
afternoon I mean obviously big
businesses the likes of Sainsbury's
who've been railing against this today
they actually pay more business rates
than a lot of the smaller members that
you may have well I think the the issue
sits right across the industry so retail
as a whole pays more than two pounds two
pounds thirty one for every one pound in
corporation tax so it's a it's the
biggest it's the biggest tax that the
industry pays and the what we've got
basically is a attacks that is the
highest compared to any other developed
country in the world so while on the one
hand we've got corporation tax that's
the lowest in the the g20 or the g7
whichever it was that the Secretary of
State was mentioning earlier is a sort
of complete disparity with a property
tax system that has just gone out of
line and needs to be sort of updated and
made fit for purpose for the current
modern way of doing business so what's
been announced today will it save jobs
will it prevent some people in retail
sector from losing their jobs do you
think I think
the margins certainly absolutely it will
help some of the the smaller businesses
some of those hit hardest but in the
scheme of you know what needs to change
over the the medium term in addressing
some of the fundamentals of a system
that that it was invented hundreds of
years ago and it just isn't fit for
purpose in in the modern world well
Chris let me bring you in at this point
the the cost of lower national insurance
contributions for the self-employed was
due to hit six billion pounds by 2020
that couldn't really continue could it
well that's the headline figure Ian but
of course that cost is offset by the the
gain unemployment that has the Britons
enjoy since 2008 which is largely due to
self-employment in other words you have
a lot more people working you would have
otherwise but the Chancellor was making
the point in his speech that's
self-employed and employed people both
make demands of public services in
exactly the same way they're just not
paying for it the same and now they
should do well that's true but the
employer also received pink Sydney very
many other benefits that doesn't
necessarily come from the public purse
which the self-employed have to pay for
themselves such as pensions sick pay
holiday pay and all those things that
the employed get so if you if you look
at it that way the the trying to tax
them as if they were the same is just
blatantly unfair but the main point of
national insurance contributions or so
we're always told is it's all about
entitlement to the state pension since
the government introduced the new state
pension self-employed workers now build
up their entitlements at the same rate
as the employee so there's less of a
need for this difference is that well
I'm not entirely sure that's that's
accurate I think that the government
fastest building the building up the new
state pension has also mandated auto
enrollment which the self-employed have
to pay off their own pockets rather than
their employers pockets the government
making the points that any self-employed
person whose profits less than 16 and a
quarter thousand every year they'll see
no increase in their nicks whatsoever I
mean how many self-employed people make
more than that there'd be a considerable
number of sixteen thousand two hundred
fifty
is not very much above the the the tax
threshold as it stands at the moment but
in fact this will hit everybody starting
at 16 250 all the way up and it doesn't
take very long to get quite a
considerable sum of money in the mid
thirties
well Helen talking of national insurance
employers also pay national insurance
contributions at thirteen point eight
percent that's kind of the elephant in
the room in this discussion it didn't
really get mentioned at all it's a
significant disincentive to hire people
isn't it well I think that's you know
where gain comes back you were asking
about what retailers are saying to me
what they're saying to me is if you look
across all of taxes so property
intensive people intensive businesses
like many retailers up and down the
country or getting overtaxed relative to
their contribution in the economy and
that is what actually hits local
investment in local Jaw in local jobs in
local communities in particularly those
communities that are perhaps more
vulnerable and and that's the real the
big sort of society worried question we
need to ensure that what we have is a
tax system whether it's for people in
the in the wider parts of the economy or
for businesses that actually is is fit
for purpose in terms of the way that the
modern the modern economy actually works